can you please tell us a little bit more
about where you come from and maybe also
a little bit about this movement for
Democratic Change here in Zimbabwe well
thank you so much it's a great pleasure
to be ya
my name is Douglas Mansoura I am the
Secretary General of the Movement for
Democratic Change which is the main
opposition parties Republican we are
hoping to form the next government I am
a lawyer by profession I I studied law
at the University of Zimbabwe I joined
the politics in 1988 fighting against a
one-party state in Zimbabwe dragged
quite a number of political parties for
purposes as a young person profiled
Afghanistan one-party state dictatorship
if the result of my fight against the
one-party state I have been arrested and
detained by the authorities in about 34
times thank God I'm alive and I am here
to tell the story I was lucky enough to
be appointed the co-chairperson of the
Constitution meeting by the Prime
Minister Mr Graham who is the president
of my part two it was an honor to be
asked to write a constitution for your
country and when we were drink that
project I my eyes were opened to the
effect that it is not what I want that
met us everyone and that as as human
beings we must be we must be able to
accommodate others there are other
interest groups there and when you are
doing a constitution
a concordance of discordant forces
within society and that the first
important thing is a constitution member
is to put yourself out of the equation
and look at society the best view of
society and the interest interest groups
that are there knowing that each
interest is as important to the person
world as your interest in something else
unfortunately after the crafting of the
new constitution which are successful
well before the custom of the new
constitution
the feature of the new constituted the
the promulgation of the new constitution
it was taken to referendum which was yes
or no words whether the people of
Zimbabwe are going to say yes to the
Constitution historically the Zimbabwe
has always voted no in the referendum
and everybody thought it would be
question of DejaVu and if the zipper was
were going to vote yes
we were going to make history and
countdown to the referendum
my colleagues and I we're afraid that is
true or repeat itself fortunately for us
the public voted 95% for the
Constitution and we became the first
group of people to do something which
went clear a referendum of which the
result was positive it was a very
humbling experience indeed
regrettably I lost my my my seat in the
ensuing election in 2013 and ever since
I
I'm in opposition I was from being an
organic cattle member of the of the
party it will be in the spokesperson of
the party in 2011 three years later I
was elected the Secretary General of the
movement and right now I have not gone
back to teaching I am running a small
private practice holding Mansoor and
associates where I have got five
partners in the lava